when I was 28 years old I was at the
bottom of a deep valley I had started
with nothing and I built a $4 million
portfolio of real estate with a million
dollar net worth and making $250,000 a
year in
1982 but I blew it I borrowed too much
money I got too far in debt and I fell
way over the edge and the year Rachel
was born I had a brand new baby a
toddler and a marriage Hanging On by a
thread and we filed bankruptcy
it was
awful I remember standing in the shower
with as hot as I could stand it in my
face and I stand there and just cry
because I was so freaking scared and I
didn't know what to do so I decided
we're going to start doing something
different and you can do something
different same is true for you